the force is what gives a jedi his power
it's an energy field created by all
living things it surrounds us and
penetrates us it binds the galaxy
together so that's a fairly deep quote
isn't it fairly deep quote and so um i
got contacted by a journalist for the
guardian they're doing an article on the
force and they wanted to know from a
physicist well what were your thoughts
on force the force of course is taken
and george lucas himself has admitted
this that it was informed by sort of
concepts of eastern mysticism and tying
together the world the universe in terms
of
almost like a spiritual force that binds
us binds us all together but it also
obeys your commands now i have a lot of
problems when it comes to quantum
mechanics for example where quantum
mechanics is abused in terms of quantum
were
and the idea that quantum mechanics
tells us that everything is bound
together and that you know brady's
electrons and my electrons are all part
of one holistic integrated whole kid
i've flown from one side of this galaxy
to the other i've seen a lot of strange
stuff but i've never seen anything to
make me believe there's one all-powerful
force controlling everything in this
universe that doesn't happen for reasons
i've discussed at length in other videos
but let's think about what you know what
what could be the origin of the force in
in star wars is there a universe where
it might be possible let's say my
starting point is existing physics and
let's think about how we would have to
modify that existing physics to um to
have something like the force in the
universe around us what's remarkable in
this universe and with current existing
physics is that quantum mechanics at one
level quantum physics does tell us that
brady's and my electrons are coupled
together binds the galaxy together does
tell us that my electrons are coupled
with the building over there are coupled
with small blue furry creatures and
alpha centauri are coupled with the
universe at whole quantum mechanics does
tell us that and in fact we can't really
think
in some ways in terms of the theoretical
context we can't think of an individual
election we've got to think of them all
coupled together it's energy
surround us
and binds us that's called entanglement
and that's that that sounds very much
like the force
but why doesn't it work in this universe
well the reason it doesn't work in
universe is that coupling is so
incredibly tiny incredibly tiny you may
as well say if i do this
that i've affected the orbit of mars
that's sort of what it's like saying
there is an effect but that effect is
not only tiny it's utterly completely
totally
fundamentally negligible it doesn't
affect anything in the world around us
you're almost making the case there
though you're saying for you and me we
can't do it but maybe a jedi who is more
sensitive or can amplify themselves but
what would have to happen so it's
interesting because um there are people
like deepak chopra there are people in
this universe in this world who claim
that this coupling happens but the
coupling doesn't happen quantum
mechanics
if you just said the coupling happens no
the coupling happens theoretically and
you have to set the theory up so that
that that um coupling is within the
theory but there's a big difference
between a theory and something that
happens practically or something that's
that's measurable
as i say the theory tells us there's a
coupling but that coupling is at the
level of it's just so far off the scale
not only could we not measure it we
couldn't even begin to hope to measure
it with whatever technology because it's
completely written overridden by any
other effect it's as i say it's like me
doing that and expecting that not only
have i affected the orbit of mars but
have affected the orbit of planets
around alpha centauri or whatever so
it's a very theoretical concept and the
problem is
not theoretical weak it does exist you
did affect mars just then just not very
much
exactly but you know so in terms of the
context of um
what it means for our everyday lives can
we control it does it make a difference
so
what would need to happen
to have something like the force in this
universe in terms of coupling us all
together well that somehow would have to
amplify that entanglement
we'd have to somehow you know in terms
of
me being able to connect with brady for
my electrons to entangle with brady's
so i could influence his thoughts for
example how would i influence his
thoughts well i'd have to change the
biochemistry and what's the biochemistry
about it's about electrons so somehow my
electrons would have to couple they'd
have to become strongly quantum
mechanically entangled with brady's
electrons
how would we do that i don't know but i
thought you said our electrons are
entangled already or electrons and we're
close to each other but that but that
level of entanglement is so absolutely
minuscule is an entanglement like
pregnant you can't be weakly pregnant
absolutely you can't be so you're
entangled or you're not no no no no no
there's a whole range of different
entire so electrons in the same atom
kind of a strong degree of entanglement
electrons in different objects kind of a
very very weak degree of entanglement
electrons on either side of the universe
that entanglement is so incredibly small
the coupling is so incredibly small that
it's just i cannot begin to describe
just how incr
incredibly and totally
minuscule and negligible it is well
professor if there are degrees of
entanglement what's the si unit for
entanglement
so well
you'd have to think of the best way of
thinking about it is in terms of
if you've got uh
no it's a very very good question brady
best way of thinking about it is in
terms of what are the energies right so
if you've got a system at one particular
energy you've got an object of one
particular energy you've got an object
over here to another particular energy
so is the energy of this object affected
by this object and vice versa that's the
best way of thinking about it so if you
bring two atoms together and what
happens is that the electrons will start
to interact they'll overlap and at some
point you no longer think of it as
individual atoms they become a molecule
right so that's a fairly strongly in
terms of the electrons that's a fairly
strongly entangled system but if you
break that out you don't need to go very
very far tall where
this atom just does not feel the
influence of this atom at all and that's
over course of just a few atomic
diameters the bond breaks so they're not
entangled they're not communicating with
each other move this to even a fraction
of a millimeter and that the the this
atom really does not care about the
presence of this atom in terms of the
the energies of the electrons in this
atom move it to the other side of the
universe
and that as i say that effect is just
completely and utterly washed out by us
breathing for one thing by the
vibrations the thermal vibrations of the
atoms in the table so the quantum
mechanics that happens down here at the
atomic level just doesn't scale up it's
almost like you're saying
sure it's there but us but but it's weak
and us mortals will never see or measure
absolutely so therefore what i'm saying
is it would take a special kind of
person to see it or control a measure
and that special person is a jedi
maybe maybe if they but they have to
they have to be able to control that
entanglement and amplify that effect
that's why they're so special yeah and
it's a question of how i guess with um i
know this divides the community and i
don't want to have hordes of rampaging
star wars fans chasing after me but
maybe this midichlorian idea maybe that
somehow amplifies the entanglement it's
an interesting idea but the the the
interesting thing here is that within as
i say within quantum mechanics in this
universe technically but i really want
to stress that technically um you you
have to couple everything together you
can't just assume one electron here you
have to consider all the electrons in
the universe so it's interesting the
force is what gives a jedi his power
it's an energy field
the force is what gives the jedi his
power
it's an energy field now already a
physicist goes hang on because a force
and an energy are very different things
many bothans died to bring us this
information
i think you're being a bit this is
semantics though isn't it the reason i
think this is semantics the force with a
capital f doesn't have to true
true that's true that's true that there
is i am being in terms of the pattern to
three i guess it can just be thought of
as um as you say
the force with a capital f rather than
air force but that distinction between
force as a physicist sees an energy is
is important but this is the this is the
really that's a bit of a pedantic point
that is a bit of a badass
but it's interesting it surrounds us and
penetrates us
basically that's what forces force
fields or fields do in the universe in
quantum field theory we think about the
the field associated with a with an
electron or a field associated with a
particle which permeates all the space
or even the electromagnetic you're used
to thinking about the hit or hearing
about the higgs boson and how that field
permeates the universe but that's true
of of every field it it does permeate
the entire universe those um
what
makes a difference is that if you make a
change here over here it can only
respond to the speed of light but that
that field in that sense does permeate
the entire universe so some of this
you know that surrounds us and
perpetrators there are fields around us
force fields
that indeed surround us and penetrate us
so in that sense you know there is some
interesting aspects of the force which
connect with us nothing more would i
teach you today
clear your mind of questions
what does a universe look like where
certain people can do it and just and
does that universe behave differently
that universe would have to be great
huge questions i'm very much thinking on
my feet here very i've given this a huge
amount of thought so please feel free to
shoot me down completely in the comments
they will indeed but um
the interesting about that is if you are
going to change the degree of
entanglement it's not just you we have
to worry about other jedi it's the
environment itself because everything
around us in this universe scatters
those waves scatters those electron
waves
and then you'd have to be able to
somehow locally
control what so if the my um
my wave function is connecting with
brady's wave function it's not just i
have to connect with brady it's i have
to get rid of the influence of this
table which might scatter that wave so
the universe would have to be here very
differently the energies would have to
be different in terms of
the
at the moment the atoms vibrating in
this table
are scattering those waves which means
that you don't have these long range
entanglements
you'd have to control all the physics
you'd even have to probably think about
changing fundamental no you would
definitely changing fundamental
constants which means that it wouldn't
just be
you brady that'll be affected or me as a
jedi knight that'll be affected the
whole universe the physics would have to
be very very different
and then it might look like a very
different place indeed there's a long
history
of
humans not understanding what was around
us gradually understanding what was
around us and then being able to harness
that to incredible effect good and bad
yeah atomic bombs are a brilliant
example yes
who's to say that in a galaxy far far
away
they haven't found a way to harness and
use entanglement to their advantage and
you just haven't thought of it yet
because you're a silly human and that is
my my problem with that is is is not as
i said it's not just a question of not
being able to design the technology it's
just that the energy scales associated
with this dear me i would love to
believe there's a universe out there
with the force that would be
absolutely absolutely fantastic that
somewhere you know there is a universe
like the star wars universe workies i'd
love to meet a rookie
if luke skywalker walked in the room
right now and used the force in front of
you he was controlling mines he was
moving things around
are you saying that quantum entanglement
would be your first line of inquiry to
figure out how he was doing it and
there's no visible sort of amplifier for
his
you know waves
i'm a jedi i can just do this stuff yes
i think it i think i'd probably start
thinking about entanglement um the other
interesting thing as well of course is
the um
the cognitive abilities or the
pre-cognitive abilities ability to see
into the into the future through the
force
things you will see other places the
future the past well it's interesting
then because in this universe we you
know the parallel worlds the whole sort
of everett many worlds theory
which again some physicists have a lot
of time for other physicists don't have
huge amount of time for but imagine a
universe where somehow you could
communicate with those other worlds
which we can't at the moment could you
tap into those other worlds could you
tap into other possibilities because the
idea is in many types of many worlds
theories that every possibility happens
could you actually couple into those
could you somehow see into the
particular universe you need to see into
this particular possibility use the
force luke
that's again a very much fundamental
quantum quantum effect but let me stress
this is all science fiction
mainly
because it's really not worth trying to
do this calculation terribly carefully
but basically it fires for a couple of
seconds so it's you know which is
accurate enough for these purposes we
need to do the math now if you want to
actually figure out what the what the
energy is so if i have a